-The wingman of Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz
pleaded guilty in court today
and promised to cooperate
fully with prosecutors.
Meanwhile, Donald Trump
is threatening to abandon
his former lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani,
who is also under
criminal investigation.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Maybe it's a coincidence,
but the MAGA crowd
seems to have a lot
of criminals in it.
I don't want to
make generalizations,
but there are more criminals
or alleged criminals
in Trump's inner circle
than there are
and a motorcycle gang
or a Hollywood PTA meeting.
If anyone ever needs to assemble
an "Oceans 11" team of criminals
for a heist, they could make one
entirely out of Trump cronies.
There's Manafort.
He's our surveillance guy.
Stone, he handles explosives.
And then there's Rudy --
he's in charge of arranging
our getaway to Jamaica.
"That's right.
Jamaica, Queens.
Holiday Inn Express
right next to the AirTrain."
"No, Rudy, Jamaica, the island."
""Okay, okay, I'll switch it,
but I can't promise
I'll get our deposit back."
Today, for example,
close friend and ally of Florida
Congressman Matt Gaetz
pleaded guilty in court
to six charges
and promised to cooperate
with federal prosecutors
as part of the plea,
which doesn't seem like
great news for Gaetz.
-Joel Greenberg,
former Florida tax official
and associate of Republican
Congressman Matt Gaetz,
was in that courtroom.
According to court filings,
he pled guilty
to six federal charges,
plans to cooperate
with federal investigators.
A criminal case
involving Greenberg
has led to a sex
trafficking investigation
of Congressman Gaetz.
-We know that there were
payments made for services
provided that we're all set up
on a website.
But in the plea agreement,
it's important to note that,
and this is where the key is,
that the defendant agrees
to cooperate fully
with the United States
in the investigation
and prosecution of other persons
and to testify,
which is another way of saying
that he has already
started to sing
and he is telling
the prosecutors everything
that he can as part
of this plea agreement.
-Yikes. I'd say Matt Gaetz
should lay low for a while,
but no matter how low he lays,
you can still see
the top of his head.
He'd make a terrible
whack-a-mole.
Maybe he'll start wearing
his gas mask again.
"Are you Matt Gaetz?"
"Me? No, I'm, uh, Daft Punk."
Obviously, this is not
good news for Gaetz.
I mean, we already knew about
the drug-fueled sex parties
and the trip to the Bahamas
with his other buddy,
"a Florida hand surgeon
and marijuana entrepreneur,"
which is one of the characters
in "Florida Clue,"
along with a vaping gator
in a Margaritaville tank top.
"Was it the vaping gator in the
Tampa Publix with a crossbow?"
"It was. It was also
everyone else, everywhere else."
We also already know
that Greenberg and Gaetz
are linked through suspicious
Venmo transactions.
[ Sighs ]
Not a good cover, dude.
Would have been less suspicious
to just use a bunch
of eggplant emojis.
Also, you know,
it's suspicious
when someone sends
tuition money on Venmo
because parents don't use Venmo.
They're like my parents.
They think Venmo
is the lost Marx brother.
[ Laughter ]
It would have been
less suspicious
if you'd just written
"for crime stuff."
Then everyone would think
it's a joke like
how you Venmo your friends
to split the check after dinner,
but you put something funny
in the subject line
like "to buy that diarrhea
medicine you asked for."
Although, side note here,
but why do we need
friends on Venmo?
It's for financial transactions.
The Wells Fargo app
doesn't have a chat room.
So obviously it's not good news
for Gaetz that Greenberg's
started to "sing,"
especially since Greenberg
has been known
for a long time
as Gaetz's wingman.
-The close ties between
Gaetz and Joel Greenberg
detailed at length
in a "Politico" piece titled
"The Congressman
and His Wingman."
Greenberg introduced him
to a handful of young women
who he met on
SeekingArrangement,
a dating website that
connects attractive women
with so-called sugar daddies.
Friends claimed Greenberg
regularly trolled
the site for dates.
The two shared more
than one girlfriend,
according to interviews
with eight friends
and associates
who know the two men.
Gaetz describe Greenberg
as a wingman
to some acquaintances
and even promoted him
as a potential
congressional candidate.
-It's not illegal,
but it does feel like
once a man hits a certain age,
that he shouldn't have
or be a wingman.
Fly solo, little bird, for you
have wings of your own.
But on the topic of wingmen,
one could argue Rudy Giuliani
served the role for Trump.
Rudy, of course, is currently
under investigation for his ties
to shady Ukrainian characters
in his effort
to dig up dirt on the Bidens
during the election,
which could, among other things,
be considered unregistered
and illegal foreign
lobbying work.
It's a sign of just how serious
this investigation is.
The feds raided Rudy's apartment
and office last month.
And yet this morning,
"The Daily Beast"
reported that Trump has blown
off Rudy's pleas for help.
First of all, if anyone
needs to be hung out to dry,
it's Rudy Giuliani.
He always looks like he fell
into the city aquarium
and got squirted
with squid ink.
Second, I'd imagine
every hour in Rudy's life
is an hour of need.
The dude butt-dials reporters,
got tricked by Borat
and doesn't know the difference
between up and down.
-From the top to the bottom,
from the middle to the side.
-[ Chuckles ]
Can you imagine trying
to give this guy directions?
If you told him
to take the D train uptown
and meet you for lunch
at the Tavern on the Green,
he'd end up on the Coney Island
boardwalk
fighting the seagull
for a half-eaten bag
of potato chips.
Also, of course, Trump is
considering
hanging Rudy out to dry.
What did Rudy think
was going to happen?
His client is famous
for not paying his bills
and turning on everyone
around him.
I'm shocked Trump hasn't called
in an anonymous tip to the feds.
"Hello. I have information
regarding criminal activity
committed by Rudy Giuliani.
What's my name? It's, uh...
Golf...Hat...
Uh, Donald Trump.
Oh, damn it.
Don't stand there while I'm
trying to think of a fake name."
"Dad, I'm so sorry!"
[ Laughter ]
Although I have to say
some of Rudy's requests
for help from Trump do seem
pretty ridiculous.
For example,
Rudy wants to prove that
the work he was doing
was for Trump,
not on behalf
of any foreign entity,
which Rudy believes
would therefore prove
that he didn't have to register
as a foreign lobbyist.
According to
"The Daily Beast"...
I'm sorry, Rudy, but Donald
Trump saves his strongly
worded written statements
for important things
like calling a horse a junkie.
Besides, I'm not sure
that would work out the way
Rudy thinks it would.
"It couldn't be illegal.
I was doing it
for Donald Trump."
Rudy is like a hit man
who thinks it will help his case
if the guy who hired him
talks to the cops.
"You guys got it all wrong.
I didn't kill that guy
for no reason.
I did it because he asked me to.
Can I go now?
Why are you handcuffing me?
Is this a Borat?
Legally, you have to tell me
if this is a Borat."
And apparently even Trump
is smart enough to know
that he shouldn't
just come out
and say Rudy was doing
all that shady
and possibly criminal work
on Trump's behalf.
So Trump isn't mad
that Rudy did a bunch
of potentially illegal stuff.
He's mad that Rudy bungled it
by hiring morons.
But, you know, when you get mad
that Rudy hired morons,
just remember, you hired Rudy.
So...
You may recall Rudy
was working with two guys
named Lev Parnas
and Igor Fruman,
AKA "The Cute One"
and "The Shy One,"
who were later arrested.
I'm not sure, but I'm guessing
that's who Trump
was referring to,
and can you blame him?
I'm not saying
these two are goons,
but they do look like the guys
who hang out
with Mugsy in "Looney Tunes."
They met with Trump.
They were photographed
with him multiple times,
including at the White House.
And after that
White House meeting...
...Hunter...
Now, if you think these guys
don't look like super spies
and Trump should have
known better, remember,
this is what Trump
thinks he looks like.
So maybe when he saw Lev
and Igor he was like,
"Wow, I feel like
I'm looking at Daniel Craig
looking into a mirror because
you were both dead ringers.
I'm going to call you 0014."
The point is, Trump is deeply
entangled in Rudy's mess,
not to mention he's got
his own legal problems,
including multiple criminal
investigations of his own.
One of those investigations,
which is being conducted
by the Manhattan DA's office, is
apparently so advanced that...
I'm guessing
the plan right now
is just to cut a hole
in the roof,
tie a hook to his toilet
and chopper him out.
It's no coincidence
that MAGA world
is full of convicted
or alleged criminals.
Fundamental to the movement's
worldview is the belief
that they are above democracy
and above the law.
It's the reason
these same people
have been pushing
the big lie
that the 2020 election
was stolen from Trump.
And yet virtually the entirety
of the Republican establishment
has decided to stand
in lockstep behind Trump.
The entire enterprise
is corrupt...
-From the top to the bottom,
from the middle to the side.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can get the donate button.
Stay safe, where a mask,
get vaccinated.
We love you.